[Música]
rusia continúa centrando su ofensiva en
el este de ucrania un alto mando del
ejército de moscú aseguró que el
objetivo además del donbass es hacerse
con el control del sur del país y
establecer un corredor terrestre hasta
la región separatista prorrusa de
transnistria hey moldavia
el proceso contra el expresidente de
honduras juan orlando hernández
extraditado el jueves a eeuu continuará
el próximo 10 de mayo el ex mandatario
requerido por narcotráfico y delitos
relacionados con armas de fuego
asistió virtualmente a su primera
audiencia a las afueras decenas de
manifestantes protestaron contra
hernández
las escuelas de samba del grupo especial
volvieron a inundar de música y color el
sambódromo de río de janeiro tras dos
años de silencio por la pandemia la
fecha coincidió con la declaración de
fin de la emergencia sanitaria por
covite en brasil tenemos reporte desde
río de janeiro
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan las jornadas hoy
valentina torre sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos en ucrania la
empresa de tecnología espacial maksar
technologies reveló imágenes satelitales
de lo que parecen ser fosas comunes a
las afueras de la ciudad portuaria de
mariupol las fotos se conocieron un día
después de que la alcaldía de esta urbe
acusar a rusia de haber enterrado hasta
9 mil civiles maksar technologies dijo
que las imágenes muestran más de 200
fosas comunes a su vez el presidente
volodymyr selenski reiteró que el futuro
del país se define con las batallas en
el este y el sur de esa nación
las fuerzas armadas de ucrania continúan
disuadiendo los ataques de los invasores
rusos en el este y en el sur de nuestro
país
la dirección de y sus bombas frías
obvias mariupol la región de gerzón son
los lugares donde está el destino de
esta guerra y el futuro de nuestro
estado legitima y mucho más intenso a
medida que rusia intensifica su ofensiva
en el este de ucrania los residentes de
severodonezk se han ido trasladando a
refugios subterráneos
los que pudieron se fueron y los que
quedan dependen de los voluntarios para
obtener los suministros y alimentos
necesarios nuestros colegas de fontur
realizaron este informe
severodonezk y el nombre de la ciudad
está inscrito con los colores nacionales
de ucrania
una ciudad industrial antes de la guerra
ahora es una ciudad fantasma casi el 95%
de los residentes han huido los
edificios dañados y bombardeados son una
vista frecuente solo quedan los que no
pueden irse a
donde quieres que vayamos a donde
con qué dinero nos vamos a ir
y no tenemos ni un céntimo y no tenemos
adónde ir
frente a este gran edificio hay un grupo
de voluntarios están ayudando a
transportar los suministros necesarios
leche en polvo carne enlatada patatas
fritas detrás del ayuntamiento otro
equipo de voluntarios misa y alexei
también están haciendo entregas es
difícil recorrer varios kilómetros
conducen por la acera durante un rato
antes de tener que bajarse y quitar las
ramas de los árboles
los voluntarios llegan finalmente a un
complejo de edificios de apartamentos
uno tras otro los residentes salen de
sus sótanos es la primera vez que
reciben suministros en más de 50 días
para estos vecinos es una oportunidad de
verse y ponerse al día
[Música]
pero la guerra no está lejos es hora de
volver rápidamente a sus refugios del
sótano esta mujer dice que las bombas
nunca paran
no tengo miedo de los rusos ni de los
ucranianos solo sé que todos los bandos
están siendo bombardeados de vuelta al
exterior es primavera en la región lo
que significa temporada de tulipanes
frente a esta cocina improvisada una
mujer con una escoba dice que está
barriendo la guerra en temas de américa
latina' la corte nacional de justicia de
ecuador formuló a bélgica un nuevo
pedido de extradición del ex presidente
rafael correa luego que fuera
oficializada una sentencia por
corrupción a pesar de la solicitud por
parte de la justicia ecuatoriana el
abogado del ex presidente indicó desde
bruselas que correa goza de asilo
político en bélgica desde hace un mes en
el marco de la ley el estatus de asilado
otorgado a correa hace que la solicitud
de extradición a ecuador sea inviable
la comunidad hondureña de nueva york- se
manifestó frente a la corte federal en
el primer día del juicio contra el ex
presidente juan orlando hernández que
fue extraditado el jueves el ex jefe del
estado está acusado entre otras cosas de
haber participado en la importación de
500 toneladas de cocaína en eeuu la
próxima audiencia está programada para
el 10 de mayo más detalles en el informe
de gabriel goal son la extradición de
juan orlando hernández se hizo efectiva
el ex presidente de honduras llegó esta
madrugada a nueva york a bordo de un
avión de la dea y este mismo viernes
asistió a su primera comparecencia ante
el tribunal federal de nueva york vía
videoconferencia hernández se limitó a
decir que conocía los cargos que se le
imputan el juicio continuará el próximo
10 de mayo cuando se presentarán las
pruebas en su contra y por ahora
permanecerá detenido a las afueras del
tribunal la comunidad hondureña se
manifestó a favor de su extradición
el final de una dictadura que ha traído
nuestro país
en violencia es un narcoestado
eeuu acusa al expresidente de haber
participado en el envío de hasta 500.000
kilos de cocaína al país y de recibir
millones de dólares en sobornos por
parte de traficantes para financiar su
compañía política e incurrir en fraude
electoral y el narcotráfico lo que trae
violencia inseguridad
pobreza muchos factores
por la misma pobreza y la misma
violencia la gente ha tenido que emigrar
hacia méxico y eeuu para poder
sobrellevar la carga y la pobreza que
hay en honduras a raíz violenta de un
arrestado el ex presidente llegue las
acusaciones y antes de su extradición
dijo haber sido injustamente sometido a
juicio los cargos contra hernández los
llevarían incluso a enfrentarse a pagar
cadena perpetua en una cárcel
estadounidense
el gobernador del estado de florida ron
de santis firmó vía express el proyecto
de ley que elimina el autogobierno y los
beneficios tributarios de los que
disfrutaba disney en sus parques de
orlando la rúbrica se produjo sólo un
día después de que la cámara estatal
aprobara la iniciativa luego de que
dicen criticar abiertamente la ley
conocida como no digas gay que limita a
hablar de orientación sexual y
diversidad de género en las aulas de
clase
ahora la gente ir a ellos si tienen
servicios utilidades nosotros vamos a
encargar de todo eso no se preocupen
todo está pensado no dejen que nadie les
diga que de alguna manera disney va a
conseguir un recorte de impuestos de
esto van a pagar más impuestos como
resultado y miles de cariocas volvieron
al sambódromo de río de janeiro para ser
partícipes de la primera de las dos
noches de presentaciones de las escuelas
de samba de la primera división en este
carnaval el primero tras dos años de
pandemia desde el lugar valeria saccone
corresponsal de france 24 nos dio más
detalles
de pandemia
del grupo de especie
tirana
de campeones
estoy con las mañanas
fue la que va a desfilar hoy
leopoldinense
efe con la mañana
años de historia
hace dos años en el último carnaval y
que este año pero me conmocionar todo
brasil porque
al carnaval
y más concurrida
española gripe española qué hacen
el coronavirus o recordamos que brasil
es el 3er país con más muertos en el
mundo más de 600 360 3000 y aquí tienen
un spoiler porque mirador o promete
hacer un homenaje en pleno sambódromo
que estuvieron en primera
en la lucha contra el coronavirus podéis
oír aquí gritos alegría mucha atención
porque es una competición no hay que
olvidar todo cuenta en esa competición
los más de 3000 componentes que tiene
cada escuela tienen que cantar tienen
que bailar tienen que sonreír y quieren
estar perfectos aquí como esas mujeres
y viva el carnaval
antes de finalizar los invitamos a
conectarse este domingo con el especial
de la segunda vuelta de las
presidenciales francesas a partir de las
12 del mediodía hora de bogotá quito y
lima
llegamos al final de este informativo a
ustedes gracias por acompañarnos
volvemos en breve con más noticias
[Música]